want to bring in Chris Mannix the senior
basketball writer for Sports Illustrated
his most recent column why did the
Grizzlies wait so long to test the
market-- on Mike Conley and Marc Gasol
let me start there Chris what are the it
feels like they're late in the game here
if you want to tank and you're you know
Memphis like what are you doing now yeah
I mean it's it's a little bit on the
late side and I look I look at it this
way
the Grizzlies they operate a little
differently because you know one of the
things I heard coming out of Memphis you
know for the last few years that if you
trade a Marc Gasol and to a lesser
degree of Mike Conley you know is the
future of the franchise at risk I mean
they don't they don't draw a great
crowds anyway during the regular season
all of a sudden you trade the ranch ice
icon you know who shows up and you know
this has always been a team that I know
there's some there's some wiggle room
when you get into the next decade about
the the lease that they have at the
FedEx Forum this has always been a team
game that's been kind of at risk of
moving down the line their owner is a
Silicon Valley guy you know they he's
based out in California so I think
there's there's been a belief that we
gotta hang on to these guys and try to
be as relevant as possible because they
know that if they traded them things
would change now some things have
changed a little bit in the last few
months I mean jaren Jackson jr. can play
like that is the building block for the
future but it does feel like they're
there they're late to this party and in
training these guys but if you're going
to have a relocation project more likely
Seattle or Las Vegas or elsewhere I'm
just guessing at this point but I think
Seattle is at the forefront I mean they
seem to be you know they seem to be
better equipped right now in terms of
building an arena they've got a fan base
I think they're the most likely team to
get the next one to get the next one
LeBron when he got injured he was listed
as day to day it's it's not now a week
tweak now we're approaching what a month
here
I was wondering bigger picture here
because let's say I'm Anthony Davis
let's say I'm a free agent here and I'm
looking at wanting to play for the
Lakers do I start to factor in like a
little
Ron has been an Iron Man here and now
all of a sudden is is would you take
something a little bit deeper with
LeBron being injured this long where
maybe he's starting to act his age and
if I'm a younger player you know is this
a concern if I look at the Lakers or am
I reading too much into this yeah I
don't know if it's overwhelmingly
concerning it's it's the first
significant injury he's had in a while I
mean he's been such an Iron Man for most
of his career and you know in a weird
way I think taking this time off might
benefit him as they go into the stretch
run and try to make the playoffs
there'll be a much pressure player at at
that point I mean there's gonna be a lot
of variables for free agents to consider
as they head into this offseason and I
don't know that LeBron look you have to
look at the brunch shelf-life and you
have to say if I team up with LeBron
James I probably have a two to three
year window of winning a championship
that might be you know different if you
go to a team like Boston or or Toronto
even well I don't I think there might be
a wider window for that but I don't
think this current injury is too big a
factor for free agents but also looking
at this season will the Lakers front
office be contempt not happy content if
they don't make the playoffs or they do
make the playoffs and they're one and
done I mean I think their mindset is if
they make the playoffs they're better
than one and done I mean I think it
would be disappointing if they got into
the postseason with the healthy LeBron
James and they can't win a first round
series now that calculus may change if
they wind up sneaking in as the eight
seed and facing Golden State in the
first round but you're not going to
convince me that the the Lakers front
office doesn't believe with LeBron that
they can't knock off a Denver or even a
Houston in a first round series so I
think they want to get into the playoffs
mostly because they believe they can
make some noise and if they make some
noise it makes them even more appealing
to some of those pre age at this summer
I know you're in Houston Rockets playing
tonight but I started to wonder I'm
watching the game the other night
against the Knicks and I kept thinking
okay Carmelo Anthony is now out there
for anybody there's talk that maybe the
Lakers bring him in if Carmelo can't
help the Rockets now
with all of their injuries and they do
need somebody who it can take a shot
from three-point range like what why
can't why can't Melo why couldn't he
play for the Rockets but now all of a
sudden you can play for somebody else
yeah I don't buy it
either I mean I think it's just kind of
the wild speculation that's out there I
mean I I saw it on social media when
Victor Oladipo goes down well Carmela
Indiana like fill in for Oladipo I mean
that's not
it's just apples and oranges there I
mean Carmelo Anthony is just he's not a
fit for today's game with what he can do
at this stage of his career as a role
player coaches value versatility it's
why at the end in Oklahoma City the
Thunder return of Jeremy grant instead
of Carmelo Anthony it's why during the
first 10 11 games of his career in
Houston Mike D'Antoni realized that
James Ennis was more valuable to him
than Carmelo Anthony if you are not you
know if Carmelo at his peak you know he
could give you 25 30 points per game it
was fine dealing with his other
weaknesses but at this stage of his
career if he's not able to be efficient
if he's not giving you 20-plus you have
to look at the other things and can he
defend well not really can he defend
multiple positions same answer is he a
great rebounder not so much so you know
if you're looking at role players
Carmelo Anthony just doesn't fit the
bill that's why the Lakers have been
they've been pretty clear they're not
going to cut somebody to bring in
Carmelo Anthony I think that's their way
of saying we don't really want it
talking to Chris Mannix Sports
Illustrated senior writer joining us Dan
Patrick show who's the best player in
the NBA right now you know based on what
I my MVP ballot right now I'd say Yanis
it's razor thin at the moment I spend a
lot of time with Kawhi over the last
month he's having an unbelievable season
Paul George I don't think it's getting
enough attention for what he's doing in
Oklahoma City but Yanis right now I mean
think about this dad who is the next
best player on Milwaukee brogdon's
Chris Miller's Middleton yeah probably
Christmas but you have to think about it
right
this is a team atop the east where
there's probably the biggest gap between
the best player and the second-best
player amongst any top-tier team in the
league I mean Kauai and Kyle Lowry
there's a gap but not as big Paul George
has got Russell Westbrook Harden that's
a separate conversation he's having a
bonkers type of season but Golden
State's got their guys there's a pretty
big gap between Yanis and everybody else
on that team
and they're still sitting right up there
at the top of the Eastern Conference
standings that's that to me is a big
factor in making Yanis the MVP all right
James Harden I I'm watching him he other
night and it's really impressive but I
you can't win this way and I said
yesterday that it feels like he's doing
this just for survival of his team like
he has to do this I don't know if he
wants to do this what do you what do you
think when you're watching this run by
Harden what stands out good and bad it
reminds me good and bad of what we saw
from Russell Westbrook in 2017 you know
we had that MVP year and he averaged a
triple-double for the first time in his
career he was just doing everything and
the usage rate if you look at those
numbers Dan they're razor thin I think
Westbrook is has one point higher than
James Hart Russell Westbrook
during that year had the highest usage
rate in NBA history James Harden is
right behind him right now and look
Russell Westbrook was great but his team
you know snuck into the playoffs as a
back end of the of the top spot of the
top eight seeds and they got beat in the
first round if it is just James Harden
doing this and Chris Paul might come
back to play tonight he will be back so
well Clint capela but if it's just James
Harden you can't win anything with it
now what's impressed me about Harden is
not just that he's putting up 36 37
points per game but he's also giving you
like eight assists
I think that's an underrated statistic
he's third in the NBA and assists when
everybody is keying on him and he
doesn't have a lot of great offensive
players around him so it's a remarkable
season
but it does have a lot of similarities
to the one Westbrook put up we brought
this up when LeBron went to the Lakers I
wondered if the NBA would try to get
their games started sooner earlier so
you got an East Coast and Midwest
audience the NBA ratings are down here I
don't hear a lot of talk as to why I
don't know if as fans we go all the best
team like Golden State's starting later
the Lakers with LeBron starting later I
don't know if that has much how big of
an impact that has why do you think the
ratings are down I think it has an
impact I think the fact that you know
LeBron leaving the East in those seven
o'clock 7:30 starts not being as
appealing I think Kawhi being in Toronto
I mean the Raptors are a great team but
that doesn't do a lot for national us TV
ratings Boston struggling I think is is
a factor in all that if the Celtics
we're off to one of those you know
Golden State from a couple of years ago
type of starts you could have really
built the narrative that super team in
the East super team in the West watched
these guys in the regular season I don't
think there's one thing though I do
agree that the West Coast start times
and the stars kind of clustering in the
West is a factor I think it's a multiple
things though that have contributed safe
travels Chris good to talk to you have
fun in Houston hi dad that's Chris
Mannix the Sports Illustrated senior
writer for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]